et salut c moi septembre alors on va
dire que c'est la saison 2 et j'ai même
fait un petit générique avec les moyens
du bord
si vous voulez me soutenir et aider au
référencement de la chaîne n'hésitez pas
partage abonnement commentaires cloche
et c'est bon on disait c'est le mois de
septembre c'est la rentrée vous avez
passé de bonnes vacances ou peut-être
que vous êtes resté chez vous dans la
grisaille ou alors peut-être que vous
avez eu la chance de voir sur instagram
des supers photos de vacances pendant
que vous étiez bloqué chez vous parce
que vous n'avez pas pu partir a
heureusement qu'ils sont là les gens qui
postent des photos de leurs vacances ça
permet à ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de voyager un peu malgré tout comme par
procuration blague à part c'est quoi
cette violence symbolique de ouf chaque
été c'est la même chose une gigantesque
compétition prend place je ne parle pas
du tour de france ni l'euro ni les yo je
pars de la coupe du monde des vacances
ce grand moment où tous les gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens de partir en
vacances dans des destinations de rêve
sont renvoyés à leurs conditions
matérielles par celles et ceux qui
s'offrent des voyages extraordinaires
et cette violence symbolique et donc
répété à la rentrée c'est le moment où
on peut avoir la chance de vivre ce
genre de débriefing de vacances
c'était sourire mais imaginez ça avec
enfants
ouais c'est dur c'est encore pire quand
il fait moche comme cet été par exemple
quand la carte de france ressemble à ça
en gros ceux qui ont les moyens d'aller
sur la côte d'azur ou à l'étranger
peuvent profiter du soleil c'est une
chose de ne pas pouvoir partir pendant
ses vacances c'en est une autre quand
l'impossibilité de partir implique
d'avoir un ciel gris au dessus de sa
tête tout le long de ses congés le
soleil a un vrai effet sur le moral
qu'on aura raccords sont sous la pluie
c'est triste et la tristesse sa fatigue
et la fatigue ça rend triste il faut le
dire sans surprise ce sont ceux qui
auraient le plus besoin de vraies bonnes
vacances qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
l'offrir les métiers les plus pénibles
et les plus fatigant ne permettent
jamais de vivre de longues vacances
paradisiaques
l'inversé vrai aussi les métiers qui
permettent de telles vacances ne sont
jamais les plus désagréables c'est un
anime effets pervers de la grande
compétition pour jouer aux capitalistes
plus on est privilégié plus on est
privilégiés plus alliés facile plus on a
des opportunités et moi on est
privilégiés pulliat de difficultés
d'obstacles à surmonter et c'est les
vacances révèle bien la systématisation
des injustices par exemple quand on est
riche on ait les moyens de louer une
belle maison près de la mer mais parfois
on n'a même pas besoin de dépenser son
argent pour louer cette belle maison
près de la mer parce qu'être riche ça
veut dire aussi avoir des amis riches
peuvent vous invitez valant belle maison
près de la mer de l'autre côté les
pauvres n'ont pas d'amis riches pour
leur permettre d'accéder à des
destinations de rêve à moindre coût au
contraire quand on est pauvre on doit
tout payer soi même cette photo je les
prie sur le site d'alter échos le titre
de l'article était celui ci sauf que
justement pendant les vacances certaines
inégalités se font plus visible est
d'autant plus à rien des smartphones où
tout le monde partage ou sans voix ses
photos de vacances
impossible de ne pas savoir où son parti
nos amis savoir les amis au paradis
quand soi-même on prend la pluie ça peut
être un peu douloureux il ya une espèce
de cercle vicieux on bosse dur donc on a
besoin de repos donc on met une certaine
pression sur ses vacances qui doivent
compenser la pénibilité de notre travail
donc on cherche à passer les meilleures
vacances possibles et on voit les
vacances des autres on compare parce
qu'on ne peut pas faire autrement
il ya toujours quelqu'un pour avoir
passé des vacances plus spectaculaires
alors progressivement nos attentes
deviennent de plus en plus exigeante on
rêve de ski de côte d'azur le maire
transparentes etc mais pour vivre de
telles vacances il faut de l'argent
alors on retourne au travail on s'épuise
et on met de côté pour le moment ça crée
des congés
si on arrive à obtenir ces vacances tant
désiré si on passe effectivement des
super vacances alors inévitablement on
renvoie à leurs difficultés matérielles
c est ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se les
offrir bref on fait des envieux et ya
rien de très glorieux à faire des
envieux dans une société inégalitaire à
ce propos vous pouvez aller voir cette
vidéo ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est d'essayer d'éclairer une manière
qui à l'idéologie capitaliste et
bourgeoise de s'infiltrer dans notre
existence et dans dictée certains
aspects voilà la question je veux poser
de quelle maladie existentielle ce désir
de passer de super vacances étaient le
symptôme
dans les derniers formats courts
j'essayais de déconstruire une
injonction relativement fréquente
aujourd'hui et qui sous couvert de bon
sens et de sagesse entretien en nette
hausse une disposition d'esprit qu'on
pourrait dire consumériste en invitant
les gens à profiter du moment présent on
indique qu'il faut rentabiliser sa vie
ses expériences qu'il faut à tout prix
vive les choses intensément
je crois que les vacances révèle bien
cela et ce dès l'enfance celles et ceux
qui ont détesté l'école de ça ferait
bien les vacances étaient attendus de
pied ferme et elle semblait toujours
passé extrêmement vite la veille du
retour à l'école on pouvait avoir
l'impression d'avoir gâché ses vacances
ou au contraire d'en avoir bien profité
ce qui se passe à mon avis est que moi
on aime aller à l'école ou quand on est
adulte moi on aime aller au travail plus
on met de pression sur le temps libre le
moment des congés c'est du temps pour
soi et rien que ça suffit à votre une
certaine pression très vite on est
conduit à penser quelque chose comme je
me dois à moi même de passer de bons
moments sur mon temps libre pour toutes
les personnes qui travaillent pour payer
les factures et non par passion pour
leur métier c'est-à-dire pour
l'écrasante majorité des gens le temps
libre c'est le moment où enfin on peut
vivre pour soi on peut choisir ce qu'on
fait
le moment notre action cesse d'être
entièrement contrainte par une
hiérarchie mais la manière même dont le
temps de travail et les congés sont
organisés va déterminer la façon dont
nous allons vivre les vacances
imaginons un monde où il n'ya pas de
vacances mais où par exemple on ne
travaille que trois jours par semaine ou
alors on travaille que le matin le
rapport au temps libre serait très
différent peut-être que nous n'aurions
pas cette terrible impression de fatigue
de ne plus en pouvoir qui donne le
sentiment d'avoir besoin de repos parce
que le travail ça prend du temps et de
l'énergie le temps libre restant est
souvent consacrée au repos parce qu'on
est fatigué alors ici comment serait
moins fatigués peut-être que le temps
hors travail serait réservé à des
projets combinerait sur plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années au lieu de taden
autrement là nous on est dans une
logique un peu abrutissante consiste à
se tuer à la tâche puis à prendre 15
jours pour sortir la tête de l'eau et si
on prend les 15 jours pour se reposer
complètement ont fini par avoir
l'impression de ne rien faire d'autre
que travailler soit je bosse soit je me
repose ça peut donner un sentiment de
vide mais en même temps la pression au
travail est telle qu'on a effectivement
besoin de déconnecter de se changer les
idées et ce sans faire trop d'efforts vu
qu'on a déjà bien fait c'est la logique
du divertissement au sens le plus simple
faire quelque chose qui nous permettent
d'oublier la partie difficile de
l'existence et quelle est cette chose
qui permet efficacement d'oublier le
côté relou de la vie c'est le plaisir ce
qui tombe très bien d'ailleurs pour une
société qui valorise le travail et la
productivité parce que si on peut pas
acheter le bonheur on peut bien au
contraire acheter le plaisir plus les
gens travaillent plus ils produisent et
plus ils sont fatigués quand le travail
devient trop pénible on profite de son
temps libre pour confirmer du plaisir
pour oublier pour passer du bon temps or
ce plaisir il est lui-même produit par
le travail des autres tout ça va donc
dans le sens de l'idéal productiviste
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez faire en
15 jours qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre pour rendre la vie tolérable que
de se jeter sur ce qui est agréable
c'est pas en quinze jours qu'on re
définit le sens de l'existence c'est pas
en quelques semaines de congés par an
disséminés ça et là qu'on atteint la
sagesse comprend un recul sur nos modes
d'existence en est sous pression toute
l'année on travaille dur on a des soucis
alors les vacances deviennent le moment
de l'oubli le moment où on s'autorise à
être heureux à être insouciants
du coup tout ça participe d'une grande
confusion entre le plaisir et bonheur on
finit par croire qu'être heureux c'est
être en train de qui fait la vie d'alors
régi par deux pour le contraire soit je
souffre soit je prends du plaisir ce qui
se transforme en rapport d'équivalence
si je souffre je suis malheureux si je
prends du plaisir je suis heureux ce qui
peut d'ailleurs devenir si je souffre ma
vie ratée si je kiffe vie réussie donc
on cherche des sources de kif des moyens
de jouir cette recherche n'est pas si
simple alain py dont des échecs des
frustrations et des déceptions
si le plaisir est l'objectif ultime où
l'unique objectif tout ce qui nous
emmène wayne ou fait obstacle est
synonyme de souffrance ce que dit n'a
rien d'original plus nous désirons de
choses plus ne nous exposons à des
frustrations possible et ce qui est
parfois étrange à rappeler c'est que la
douleur induite par cette frustration
sont bien réels quel que soit le
contexte
[Musique]
imaginez john smith un jeune homme de 16
ans fils d'un milliardaire de la silicon
valley pour son anniversaire et pour
célébrer son permis de conduire john a
demandé à son père une lamborghini mais
son père n'ayant pas réussi à obtenir ce
modèle fabriqué à très peu d'exemplaires
lui a acheté une ferrari à la place john
qui rêve de cet impôt qui nie depuis des
mois est dépité en découvrant la ferrari
sa déception le submerge il s'effondre
en larmes il crie et d'un coup de pied
dans la roue du bolide il perd ses
moyens la douleur de john paraît
totalement illégitime bien sûr parce que
nous l'observons avec un regard social
politique morale et de ce point de vue
rien ne peut la justifier elle est
politiquement moralement légitime mais
d'un autre côté john est une victime
d'une part de son conditionnement social
qu'il invite à rêver de ce genre de
voiture à croire profondément que la
valeur d'une personne tient à ce qu'elle
possède il a été comme contraint par son
environnement a adopté ce système de
croyances et de valeurs
d'autre part il est victime de son
conditionnement psychologique qui l'a
enfermé dans une incontrôlable gic
désirante il subit sa psyché pour john
on pourrait dire que c'est toute sa vie
tout le sens de son existence qui se
joue dans chaque objet désiré s'il ne
tient pas ce qu'il veut un vide abyssal
ça fait sentir en lui on peut considérer
john ridicule autant qu'on veut mais on
peut aussi le voir comme une victime et
on peut aussi reconnaître sa douleur
aussi illégitime soit elle du point de
vue social sa douleur en est pas moins
réelle du point de vue psychologique et
on peut garder ces deux dimensions à
l'esprit la douleur de john n'a pas le
même sens selon qu'on observe à travers
un prisme collectif ou individuel
le caprice de john est absurde mais il
souffre vraiment la douleur de john qui
a en partie à une forme de confusion on
pourrait dire que john s'est autorisé à
penser que la lamborghini lui était dû
il s'attendait à la voir et parce qu'il
s'attendait à la voir pourrait même
ajouter ceci il considérait y avoir
droit si john est aussi triste d'avoir
une ferrari à la place de la voiture de
ses rêves c'est qu'ils pensaient qu elle
lui était acquise c'est pourquoi il
ressort de la déception
la vie ne fut pas à la hauteur de ses
attentes
évidemment les éléments j'ai choisi pour
cet exemple sont caricaturaux il n'y a
rien qui puisse sembler légitime dans le
fait de voir
tueur de luxe et cela paraît encore pire
quand on ajoute que l'idée de du
personne ne devrait considérer avoir
droit à une voiture de luxe et
d'ailleurs les voitures de luxe ça ne
devrait même pas exister mais il faut
aussi reconnaître qu'on retrouve la même
attitude la même disposition d'esprit la
même structure désirante dans des
situations qui nous semble beaucoup
moins problématique en termes de
légitimité
voilà jammes elle a eu une année
difficile
elle a changé de job et sa petite amie
l'a quitté soudainement deux gros
changement qui l'ont conduit à devoir
déménager jeanne est fatigué et attend
ses vacances avec impatience le mois de
juillet arrive enfin elle va pouvoir
partir se reposer pendant dix jours en
bretagne au bord de la vilaine sauf que
non c'est l'été 2021 célèbre pouffant
temps de merde il pleut tous les jours
les vacances de jeanne sont gâchées
jeannette reid frustré en colère même et
si nous est plus facile de nous
identifier à jeanne cas john il ne reste
pas moins que la confusion est la même
jeanne comptait sur le beau temps elle
s'était imaginé se baigner dans la
rivière et son rêve lui ait volé la vie
ne fut pas à la hauteur de ses attentes
si jamais ces deux exemples en parallèle
c'est pour montrer que si on met de côté
les enjeux sociaux une seconde pour se
concentrer sur le phénomène
psychologique on découvre une identité
de structures dans le rapport au désir
et je crois que ce rapport au désir met
en lumière un enjeu qui est précisément
sociale l'idéologie capitaliste dans
laquelle nous baignons nous conduit non
seulement à vouloir posséder des objets
mais également des choses immatérielles
certains s'imaginent pas d'être libre de
toute détermination capitaliste
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
spécialement de désir consumériste parce
qu'ils n'achètent jamais rien mais c'est
un peu naïf gardons à l'esprit que le
capital n'est pas seulement économique
et matérielle
on pourrait dire que ce que john
souhaite posséder ce n'est pas tant cet
ensemble de carrosserie qui roulent vite
mais bien plutôt le symbole associé à
l'objet lamborghini avec le modèle rêvé
john aurait renvoyé une certaine image
de sa personne c'est là dessus qu'il
comptait c'est son identité qui était en
jeu c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on évoquait
avec baudrillard dans cette vidéo aussi
le jour de son anniversaire john n'a pas
l'impression de recevoir une autre
voiture mais plus précisément qu'on lui
retire une opportunité narcissique à
savoir un objet dont il aura été
particulièrement hier ce dont rêvait
john c'est de la fierté bien précises
qui accompagne dans son esprit le
propriétaire de cette lamborghini
quentin jeanne ce qu'elle voulait
posséder est également immatériel jeanne
voulait posséder un moment c'est-à-dire
pour employer à nouveau ce mot aux
connotations mercantile jeanne voulait
profiter du moment pour profiter de ces
vacances un facteur indispensable était
le beau temps mais c'est quoi profiter
de ses vacances avoir rentabilisé son
temps et ça veut dire quoi si je devais
faire un pari je dirais que ça veut dire
prendre autant de plaisir que possible
profiter de ses vacances ce serait
quelque chose on atteint à partir d'une
certaine quantité de plaisir pour
certaines personnes un rayon de soleil
ou une baignade leur suffit à dire que
cela a fait leur journée on s'est baigné
une fois cette journée ne fut pas perdu
pour d'autres il en faut plus il faut de
baignade par jour et des dîner bien
arrosé ponctuée de suffisamment d'éclats
de rire parfois ça ne se mesure pas
vraiment évidemment c'est simplement une
affaire de bien-être on dira qu une
bonne journée c'est une journée où on a
réussi à oublier ses soucis
tout repose sur le réflexe de classe et
les moments en deux catégories les
moments plutôt désagréable qu'on veut
éviter autant que possible et qui quand
il s'impose nous rendre impatient on
attends tu passes et les moments
agréables les moments de plaisir qui me
donne le sentiment que l'on profite de
la vie et qui passe trop vite
ces moments dont on dit que c'est eux
qui font que la vie vaut la peine d'être
vécue
j'insiste donc encore une fois pour
mettre en avant la tonalité économique
et capitaliste de notre rapport à
l'existence après profiter et
rentabiliser on a ici le verbe valoir
qui entretient l'idée que certains
moments de vie peuvent valoir plus que
d'autres que l'on prévert certains
moments c'est une chose mais considérer
qu'ils valent davantage voilà une
disposition mentale qui n'est pas
anodine du tout et ça ressemble donc
bien à une disposition tourné vers la
rentabilité on aurait tendance à évaluer
notre vie selon le même genre de mindset
que celui de l'investisseur financier
pour savoir si un moment est un bon
moment on regarde combien on a investi
de temps et d'efforts et combien il a
rapporté de plaisir nous sommes des
capitalistes de l'existence eh oui si
cela le sens de la déception c'est quand
un événement n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'espoir que nous avions 1 en lui dans
le cas de john il avait investi
énormément de temps à fantasmer sur le
fait de recevoir un lamborghini le jour
de son anniversaire la joie imaginé est
attendu n'ayant pas eu lieu il vit son
anniversaire comme un moment raté peu
importe la ferrari jeanne avait parié
sur le fait que cette quinzaine de
juillet serait ensoleillé elle avait
investi son espoir sur des vacances
agréables cet état d'un investissement
sans risque à ses yeux puisque c'est un
mois où il fait beau généralement et
elle comptait sur le soleil pour que ces
jours en bretagne représente un réel
retour sur investissement mais la météo
a tout gâché jeanne n'avait pas
simplement besoin de repos elle avait
aussi besoin de plaisir nous demandons
si nous profitons bien la vie tout
simplement et en se posant cette
question on se met dans une position
d'arbitré contraint d'évoluer chaque
moment notre existence de les placer sur
un spectre du cauchemar au rêve en somme
on se met à juger la vie et on la juge
en fonction de nos désirs mais nous ne
sommes pas les hauteurs de l'un des
siens puisque nous héritons voir
subissons les désirs tout fait puisque
notre héritage familial culturel notre
environnement nous invite à désirer ceci
plutôt que cela donc nous évoluons la
réussite et l'échec de notre vie à
l'aune de critères arbitraires qui nous
sont tombées dessus de manière plus ou
moins explicite c'est un peu dommage non
non seulement on passe notre temps à
distinguer les moments réussis des
moments raté non seulement on souffre de
chaque moment qu'on l'identifié comme
ratée mais en plus on nous a imposé des
critères qui permettent la distinction
voilà une forme très nette domination on
nous contraint sans que l'on s'en rende
compte à désirer x et nous souffrons de
ne pas obtenir un x
[Musique]
revenons à la question des vacances
lordon évoque ce problème du désir dans
son livre marx et spinoza quoique de
manière un peu alambiquée vous avez
remarqué d'ailleurs les différences
entre leurs dons à l'oral et leurs dons
les cris quand il parle il est super
clair quand il écrit on dirait qu'il
fait un concours d investissement bref
j'ai jamais trop compris pourquoi ils
utilisaient un concept aussi abstrait
que son histoire d'angle alpha pour une
idée somme toute assez simple il s'agit
tout bêtement d'un alignement des désirs
en gros disons que je suis le
propriétaire d'un bateau type galère et
que j'ai envie de m'en servir pour aller
d'un point a à un point b et bien si
j'arrive à convaincre les gens que leur
désir c'est de ram et ils ont envie de
ramener toute la journée et bien c'est
tout bénef pour moi c'est la même
histoire et des entreprises le patron a
tout intérêt à ce que ces employés et
des désirs qui coïncide avec ses
ambitions c'est pourquoi on parle de
culture entreprises ont fait du team
building etc on cherche à devenir vieux
aux employés de se donner pour leur
boîte un gros avantage c'est que ça
élimine les rapports conflictuels pas
besoin de contraindre les gens à agir
d'une certaine manière s'ils en ont eux
même envie on peut retrouver des
problématiques similaires dans les
vacances à plusieurs même si ça peut
arriver qu'on s'engueule en général en
charge thème à éviter autant que
possible les confrontations entre
violente alors que se passe-t-il
imaginons trois couples qui loue une
maison ensemble alice et alex camille et
claude fred et dominique et partons du
principe que ces six personnes sont
plein de bonne volonté il ne reste pas
moins que ces six individus ont leurs
propres désirs et que ceux ci ne sont
pas toujours parfaitement compatibles
entre eux un désir c'est une force au
sens où c'est quelque chose qui nous
fait tendre regard d'objectifs qui nous
met en mouvement
mais on n'a pas tout à fait à faire
ainsi désir distincts d'abord chaque
individu est constitué d'une
multiplicité de désir ensuite certains
désirs sa ligne de même sans difficulté
par exemple l'apéro mais on a aussi dit
qu'il y avait trois couples ces couples
peuvent former des duos des équipes il
peut être plus facile pour eux des
lignes et leurs désirs
chacun de ces coupes s'il passait des
vacances seuls tendrait vers une
certaine forme un rythme un choix
d'activités plutôt que d'autres une
ambiance particulière etc mais peut-être
que tous ensemble alice 1 exprès des
dominique vont subir la forme de camille
et claude c'est à dire passer des
vacances qui ressemble davantage aux
vacances que passera camier claude 6e
coupe était partie seule aux vacances
calice alex frêle et dominique aurait
passé seul
on peut imaginer trois pôles désirant
différents alice et alex veulent faire
une balade en vélo camille et que
devrait aller au musée fred et dominique
veulent faire des courses pour le dîner
on pensera peut-être et bien pas de
soucis chacun fait son truc dans son
coin sauf que ce n'est pas toujours
aussi simple très souvent des petites
contraintes logistiques suffisent à
mettre en tension les désirs peut-être
que pour aller au musée ou faire les
courses on a besoin de vélo et peut-être
qu'il n'y a pas assez d'antivol pour
séparer les six vélos cela impose à nos
trois couples de mettre en marche un
processus de décision tu peut générer
des petits conflits d insatisfaction
mais il peut y avoir des raisons plus
fondamental à l'origine d'une tension
peut-être que fred et dominique
considère qu'il est urgent de faire les
courses et que c'est une corvée qu'il ou
elle ne devrait pas assurer seuls
camille et claude sont d'accord avec
près de dominique mais c'est le dernier
jour de l'exposition il le musée leur
sont donc prioritaires comment
décide-t-on la question de la décision
se confond ici avec celle de l'autorité
quelle personne qui al'idée quel
principe va faire autorité quel va être
le critère qui va intervenir
explicitement ou implicitement pour
orienter la prise de décision et donc
validé un des trois désir si je prends
cet exemple dans une vidéo autour du
capitalisme c'est pour mettre en lumière
l'idée que sous couvert d'égalité
d'originalité c'est à dire en l'absence
de hiérarchie officielle est explicite
des rapports de pouvoir et de domination
émergent malgré tout à partir des désirs
de mail on entend parfois parler du
libre marché des idées c'est une espèce
de fantasme qui suppose que les idées
circulerait tout librement et que ce
serait donc les meilleures idées qui
s'imposent on oublie tous les rouages
explicites ou implicites les conditions
matérielles bref tous les éléments de la
réalité qui favorise la diffusion de
certaines idées au détriment d'autres on
oublie en fait la puissance d' influence
des normes et des habitudes c'est pareil
ici il faut se demander comment
l'autorité se forment-elles pendant les
vacances selon quels critères
la première chose à relever c'est qu'il
faut bien distinguer l'autorité
explicite de l'autorité implicite si
alice et alex 10 pendant ces vacances
c'est nous qui décidons alors c'est un
cas assez particulier et les quatre
autres auront à se positionner vis-à-vis
de cette prise de pouvoir
ce qui nous intéresse ici c'est bien
plutôt les rapports de domination
discret quasi imperceptible alors
l'autorité peut c'est à dire de manière
différente
mettons que camille et claude avait déjà
loué cette maison de l'an passé où ont
déjà passé des vacances dans la région
peut-être alors que leur connaissance de
l'endroit alors conférera une sorte d'
ascendant pour ce qui est de décider des
balades à faire ou des restaurants où
aller camille claud diront on avait été
par ce petit chemin c'était ravissant où
on avait été très déçu par ce restaurant
tandis que celui ci était délicieux ces
petites phrases toutes bêtes ont une
force de persuasion d'abord on est
habitué à respecter l'expérience a
considéré le savoir et celles et ceux
qui ont déjà fait quelque chose
naturellement une espèce d'autorité des
coûts de cette position de sa chance
c'est une norme et d'autres normes
peuvent intervenir par exemple et
convention sociale onss interdira de
faire quelque chose parce que ça ne se
fait pas alice ne s'autorisera pas à
travailler à 14 heures même si c'est ce
qu'elle allait faire parce que ça ne se
fait pas parce que tacitement on
s'attend à déjeuner tous ensemble et
c'est
l'autorité peut aussi venir du collectif
si alice alex camille et claude se
connaissent mieux peut-être qu'il leur
sera plus facile de se mettre d'accord
et peut-être que frêle et dominique se
sentiront obligés d'aller dans leur sens
l'autorité peut venir du caractère des
individus peut-être que camille claud
dont une autorité naturelle ils ou elles
prennent facilement les devants font des
propositions arguments à nîmes en faveur
d'une décision etc de sorte que les deux
autres couples se laisseront influencé
voire convaincre
peut-être même calice alex fred et
dominique ne prendront même pas
conscience de leur désir de ce qu'il ou
elle avait envie de faire part que
camier claude les auront mis face à un
certain choix peut-être qu'une dynamique
de groupe installée elle même
privilégiant les activités au détriment
du farniente un cause d'un système de
valeur implicite par ce qui peut
paraître plus difficile de revendiquer
son désir de glander dans une chaise
longue que son désir de vouloir faire
une exposition le fait d'être actif et
souvent davantage valoriser ce que je
veux souligner ici c'est qu'en fonction
des contextes certains désirent
paraissent plus légitime que d'autres
c'est une histoire de normes et les
normes c'est un peu l'effet de neige il
est plus facile d'exprimer un désir qui
paraît légitime et par conséquent on
exprime - les désirs considéré comme
moins légitime et parce qu'on les
expriment moins ils ne parviennent
jamais à gagner en légitimité
c'est pas facile à vivre quand ne sont
pas légitimes de désirer quelque chose
quand on a l'impression qu'on ne peut
pas exprimer ce qu'on voudrait faire
parce que ça irait contre l'ordre
naturel des choses
de l'autre côté les désirs légitimes
mais renvoie à des plaisirs considéré
comme légitime et si un contexte social
et culturel participe à légitimer
certain plaisir ce qui se passe c'est
que cela encourage des individus à
chercher tel ou tel plaisir en somme le
pouvoir de la norme c'est celui de nous
faire croire qu'on a de bonnes raisons
de prendre du plaisir à faire ceci et à
ne pas aimer faire cela et comme on
dirait cela fait boule de neige cette
idée qu'on a raison de prendre du
plaisir ajoute du plaisir au plaisir ce
qui rend l'activité encore plus
désirable et comment la tendance avant
le plaisir comme le but ultime on subit
encore davantage notre désir il est très
difficile d'interroger son vin pur
plaisir il me semble que les vacances
représentent l'occasion de remarquer
comment s'organisent parfois malgré soir
la gestion collective des désirs et des
plaisirs c'est un moment opportun pour
apprendre sur soi
[Musique]
pour illustrer sa est terminée cette
vidéo je voudrais vous raconter un petit
conte taoïste que ma mère me racontait
quand j'étais petit et que j'ai mis près
de 30 ans à comprendre vraiment je vous
fais la version courte et abréger c'est
la fête du village et celle ci se clôt
avec une tombola le fils d'un paysan
gagne le premier prix un cheval
lendemain le voisin du paysan bien le
voir il le dit waouh quel chance il a eu
ton fils le premier prix un cheval le
paysan répond oui rare durant deux jours
passent le fils du paysan montage parle
pour la première fois est immédiatement
tombe et se casse la jambe le voisin de
paysans vient le voir obasi dans quelle
poisse à peine il reçoit son cheval
qu'il se casse la jambe le paysan répond
or verra on verra une semaine plus tard
le japon déclare la guerre à la chimie
tous les jeunes du village sont appelés
à partir ou sauf que lui du paysan qui
réformaient puisqu'il a la jambe cassée
le voisin bien le voir quelle chance il
a eu ton fils se casser la jambe juste
avant la guerre le paysan répond on
verra
trois mois plus tard les jeunes du
village reviennent de guerre plein de
décoration et d'histoire 0 hic ils sont
célébrés lors d'une grande fête le
voisin revient à voir le paysan il lui
dit ah il n'a pas de chance mon fils il
ne peut pas être célébrée ce soir le
paysan répond à en verra on verra quand
je dis que j'ai mis près de 30 ans à
comprendre cette histoire ce que je veux
dire c'est que pendant longtemps je ne
voyais que la réaction aux mauvaises
nouvelles je ne comprenais cette sagesse
confondons le sa capacité à faire
accepter le moment désagréable et je
crois que notre problème se trouve là
précisément dans le fait que
spontanément on ne prend que la moitié
de l'histoire on se dit qu'on laissera
passer les défaites mais on continue de
s'autoriser à célébrer les victoires
sauf que non c'est manquer toute la
profondeur de cette histoire et c'est
continuer à aborder la vie comme une
succession de moments on certains valent
plus que d'autres ce qu'il faut retenir
de cette histoire c'est précisément que
le pays est en vie on verra aussi pour
les moments qui apparaissent au premier
abord comme des succès qu'on voudrait à
célébrer et moi j'ai envie d'ajouter
qu'il faut surtout le dire pour ces
moments là mais ça nous paraît
contributif et même flippant parce qu'on
a peur de ne pas pouvoir profiter si je
ne célèbre pas les petites victoires de
la vie je n'ai pas en profiter je vais
passer à côté de ma vie et encore une
fois parce qu'on confond plaisir et
bonheur cette conclusion est typiquement
capitaliste on peut consommer le plaisir
on peut l'obtenir l'acheter tant que
l'on sait par l'existence en moments
plaisants et moment désagréable on
continuera de vendre notre vie selon la
distinction moments qui font que la vie
vaut la peine d'être vécue versus moment
qui gâchent la vie une distinction qui
fait directement le jeu de la société de
consommation cela invite à consommer le
temps à chercher à obtenir des moments
plaisants
regardez comme on cherche à nous vendre
des bons moments des moments fun sympa
intense qu'ils font avec l'idée que
c'est ça une vie réussie une vie riche
de plaisir
les conditions de possibilité du plaisir
sont très souvent associées au fait
consommer les vacances donc mais aussi
dans lequel et par les restaurants on
pourrait être tenté de se demander à
côté de combien le moment les passer
simplement parce qu'il ne répondait pas
aux critères de plaisir qu'on a
intériorisé combien d'heures de nos vies
passées frustré
et suis impatient que le prochain moment
plaisant interviennent tout simplement
parce qu'on ne se laissait pas la
possibilité de vivre le moment tel qu'il
était mais ces demandes et cela c'est
retombé dans mêmes travers c'est à
nouveau se mettre la même pression
consultant à vouloir rentabiliser son
temps c'est culpabiliser d'avoir perdu
du temps à être frustré quand on aurait
pu le passer plus heureux c'est à
nouveau considéré que les moments
déplaisant sont des moments gâcher alors
soyons joyeux quand nous vivons un
moment agréable et souriant frustrés et
soyons déçus quand nous faisons face est
quelque chose de déplaisant mais ne
soyons pas dupes n'oublions pas quelles
dispositions d'esprit est impliqué dans
cette évaluation des moments observons
nous as love soyons conscients que nous
jugeons la vie et selon des critères
culturels qui plus est c'est constamment
présent il ya par exemple un plaisir
avant la métro arrivés immédiatement et
il y a une sensation désagréable à
découvrir au contraire qu'il faudra
attendre 10 minutes sur lequel on passe
notre temps à juger le moment présent
selon qu'il est plaisant ou déplaisant
et nous cherchons à maîtriser notre
quotidien pour qu'il y ait le maximum de
moments plaisants et le minimum de
mouvements déplaisant ce désir de
maîtrise et a pas rentable et un désir
de propriété chercher à être maître de
son quotidien de la qualité des moments
vécus c'est chercher à posséder les
moments plaisants je fais ce
rapprochement pour deux raisons
différentes un maîtriser son quotidien
en ce sens c'est s'arranger pour avoir
des moments plaisants sous la main ou à
disposition avoir la maîtrise des
expériences qui nous arrive c'est
pouvoir décider de vivre un moment
agréable ou d'éviter un moment
désagréable c'est donc avoir à
disposition les moyens d'obtenir ce
moment plaisant ou de fuir le moment
déplaisant par extension c'est en ce
sens posséder le moment lui-même
2 ensuite en un autre sens peut-être
plus difficile à appréhender maîtriser
nos expériences cela suppose de pouvoir
les cadres et les contrôler leur imposer
notre volonté pour qu un moment plaisant
soit un moment plaisant il ne faut pas
que plane au dessus de lui la menace de
pouvoir se transformer à n'importe quel
moment en moments franchement
désagréable tenez quand on regarde du
sport si l'équipe ont supporté mené 3-0
c'est franchement désagréable s'il ya un
an c'est tendu donc plutôt désagréable
si elle mène 1-0 c'est mieux mais on
passe par des moments d'inquiétude qui
ternissent le plaisir et si notre équipe
déroule et mène 3 0 alors là on en
profite vraiment ce désir de maîtrise et
de possession c'est donc aussi un désir
de sécurité on a envie de savoir à quoi
on peut s'attendre
c'est donc le confort de la propriété on
cherche à accumuler les conditions
favorables les éléments qui vont nous
aider à passer des bons moments durable
on théorise on capitalise sur des états
mentaux rassurant et plaisant on se
demande si le moment présent de la
valeur c'est à dire s'il va dans le sens
de notre désir si on peut en profiter et
on se met une certaine pression ne pas
être un looser ce serait savoir se
mettre en situation de vivre des moments
considérée comme réussie valoriser d'où
l'énorme pression qui intervient au
moment des vacances on accepte de subir
toute une partie de temps au travail on
accepte que ce soit plutôt déplaisant
parce qu'on a intégré l'emploi comme un
impératif mais les vacances les
week-ends le temps dit libre c'est du
temps pour soi c'est ce qu'on doit
rentabiliser pour être content on
développe une relation au plaisir qui
est analogue à la diction le moment
entre les moments de plaisir est un
temps vide qu'on voudrait pouvoir a
abrogé on organise notre vie tout
entière en fonction du plaisir qu'on
peut obtenir ou de la souffrance et à
éviter il ne nous paraît pas absurde du
tout de faire tout un tas d'efforts en
vue d'un moment censé être agréable
c'est notre habitude et donc on cherche
des moyens d'obtenir du plaisir on se
renseigne on regarde comment font les
autres on évalue sa vie en fonction de
ce qu'on voit chez le voisin on compare
la somme de plaisir dans notre vie à la
somme de plaisir dans la vie des autres
on compare notre vie avec ce qu'elles
pourraient être toujours cette
distinction entre ce qui est d'une part
et d'autre part ceux qui pourraient ou
devraient être distinction qui fait le
carburant de l'ethos capitaliste puisque
ça nous pousse à me demander y a -t-il
pas une meilleure offre quelque part une
meilleure situation et si oui comment
l'obtenir on se fait une idée de ce à
quoi on pense avoir droit de la quantité
de plaisir que les gens autour de nous
vivent et on se compare si on est plus
riche de plaisir que son voisin on est
rassuré sinon on se sent parfois on a
l'impression de rater sa vie parce qu'on
croit qu'une vie avec moins de plaisir
et une vie moins réussi c'est pour ça
que je parlais de compétition au début
de la vidéo la compétition est un moyen
de faire des comparaisons ou plus
précisément des évaluations c'est-à-dire
d'identifier ce qu'il ya de mieux voire
même le meilleur alors on fait dans
notre vie une compétition où gagner
suppose d'obtenir le maximum de plaisir
notez que cette compétition n'est pas
nécessairement tourné vers les autres
elle peut se jouer en soi même par
exemple on met en concurrence le présent
avec le passé et c'est pour ça qu'on
peut les vacances des vacances aussi
pénible ennuyeuse que le travail serait
considérée comme ratée en fait on
compare le moment en vacances au moment
travail qui précède ou à d'anciens
vacances pour évaluer sa réussite c'est
pas forcément une comparaison consciente
1 ça peut se dérouler au fond de notre
esprit mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'on cherche constamment à obtenir une
situation favorable si l'on veut se
soigner du capitaliste en nous sans
doute faut-il se pencher sur notre
rapport au plaisir et à la consommation
du temps on a forcément été contaminés
et ce jusque dans les couches de plus
profond de notre inconscient par
l'idéologie capitaliste et je crois que
pour lutter contre le capitalisme il
faut le comprendre le plus précisément
possible
pour comprendre le capitalisme il me
semble judicieux d'observer en soi même
les petites maladies les roses qui nous
a transmise pensez-y là je ne vois que
vous partez en vacances s'ils le sont
pas aussi chouette que prévu bien sûr
mais également si les chantres cool
j'espère que ça vous a plu à bientôt
[Musique]